c'est aujourd'hui qu'entre en vigueur la
réforme des retraites elle concerne les
personnes nées à partir du 1er septembre
1961 et prévoit de retarder
progressivement l'âge de départ de 62 à
64 ans a raison de trois mois de plus
par an autre mesure phare en vigueur dès
aujourd'hui la fin de la plupart des
régimes spéciaux existants si vous étiez
embauché avant-hier à la Banque de
France vous bénéficiez du régime plus
favorable qui est 10 régimes spéciales
de la Banque de France celui qui sera
embauché demain non bénéficiera pas et
donc il sera automatiquement reversé au
régime général c'est valable pour les
électriciens c'est valable pour l'éclair
de notaire etc pour les personnes ayant
commencé à travailler tôt la réforme
prévoit un dispositif carrière longue
des départs des 58 ans pour un début de
carrière avant 16 ans 60 ans avant 18
ans mais à une condition avoir cotisé 44
ans
la saison commence bien pour les
supporters de la gé Auxerre leur
entraîneur emblématique Guy Roux fait la
promotion du club de Ligue 2 sur les
réseaux et quelle promotion je crée le
compte tip-top de lasure
quoi couper à 84 ans il lâche un kuakubé
l'expression préférée des adolescents
la vidéo fait un carton d'autant qu'un
détail amuse beaucoup les plus
observateurs Guy Roux tiens son
smartphone à l'envers
enfin une expérience insolite en
Californie
Chupacabra une petite chèvre noire donne
des cours de surfotouriste en compagnie
de son maître celui-ci loue le sens de
l'équilibre naturel de son animal des
leçons dans la bonne humeur idéal aussi
pour apprendre à vaincre la peur de
l'eau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
culte
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non mais ça parait immense
ça paraît immense
[Musique]
oh
la vache
je suis trompé
c'est quoi ton bateau Maurice comme une
action parisienne pointu
et pourquoi on appelle ça un pointu
parce que c'est pointu
jeune animateur à l'époque et pour moi
se retrouver dans une piscine c'était
vraiment le sumo de l'humiliation
ou pas c'est très con mais quand je suis
sorti de cette séquence
j'ai insulté tout le monde j'ai viré de
ma loge tout le monde et vous trouvez ça
drôle j'ai des foudrages le premier
septembre
1997 et une femme détenait un record
extrêmement difficile à battre je suis
recordman de noueuse de queue de cerise
dans la bouche
on y va
attention
voilà donc elle fait un nœud avec des
queues de cerises dans sa bouche sans
sortir
elle aussi
[Musique]
mais où elle va
mec
les infos Raphaël Thomas bonjour Raphaël
bonjour Grégory bonjour à tous
ça va être dur
[Musique]
alors je viens de m'envoyer en l'air
pour une expérimentation spatiale
arboricole et c'est juste merveilleux
voilà je suis encore toutefois que c'est
ça fait un bien fou quoi on y va
[Musique]
alors les bras les bras en l'air le
menton on est avec vous
[Applaudissements]
oh là là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les cascades c'est toujours
impressionnant surtout quand c'est bien
préparé mais ça peut aussi être très
impressionnant quand c'est mal préparé
et très marrant aussi du coup grosse
frayeur pour l'un des cascadeurs les
plus suivies de la toile
yojini chez bottarev et réputé pour ses
cascades un peu prenantes mais sa
dernière a mal tourné il a fait une
chute de 15 mètres alors qu'il tentait
de sauter du toit d'un immeuble à un
autre au volant d'une voiture sur
Instagram il diffuse l'accident sous
plusieurs angles et son issus
miraculeuse car oui il en sort indemne
sur le port du Hong Kong cette nuit la
force du vent forme des vagues
incontrôlables
cet homme brave tous les dangers pour
prendre une photo il est rapidement
emporté en arrière par des rafales
lancent jusqu'à 140 km heure
c'est ici tôt ce matin que le typhon
Saoula fait ses premiers dégâts
dans les rues desertes de Hong Kong
plusieurs arbres ont été arrachés nous
l'humanité est bien on aurait pu finir
comme les dinosaures il y a environ
900000 ans on est passé pas loin de
l'extin de l'extinction précisément la
population nos ancêtres des Homo sapiens
auraient chuté à seulement 1300
individus un scénario qui aurait duré
près de 100000 ans bien sûr les
chercheurs en cause le réchauffement
climatique